alguna voluntad muy importante realmente
esta vacuna ha sido probada en más de
800.000 niños hoy en día
se demostró en la fase 3 que tiene una
eficacia hasta el 75 por ciento en niños
entre los 5 meses y los 17 meses en 4
dosis las tres primeras con un mes de
intervalo y la última al año de la
primera dosis de manera que es una
hormona de una gran esperanza para el
control y la eliminación de la malaria
además tiene un perfil de seguridad
excelente en los niños sin causar
mayores efectos secundarios si la vacuna
contra la malaria ha tenido una larga
historia de su desarrollo es una la
vacuna más difícil es porque se trata de
un parásito muy complejo que tiene
muchas estadios hasta el estadio en los
es por los ojitos que son las formas
precisamente que vienen del mosquito e
infectan a la persona en el hígado y ahí
se multiplican y producen los estadios
sanguíneos entonces es muy complejo
una vacuna contra la malaria y esta esta
vacuna producida con base en los es por
los ojitos es la forma infectante del
mosquito nuevamente a las formas
sanguíneas en el hígado
ha sido la la vacuna que más gas se ha
sostenido en el tiempo en la
investigación y con mejores resultados